Estos no son aviones comunes sobre la
pista del aeropuerto de gasia antier
llevan la ayuda tan necesaria para
aliviar la presión en los hospitales
turcos que no han sido dañados o
destruidos
a bordo de este avión de carga y 60
toneladas de material para construir el
hospital francés de campaña
dos bloques operativos hay casi todo lo
necesario para hacer funcionar un
hospital un aparato de radiografía
farmacia y esterilización y luego toda
la logística para nosotros nuestro
alojamiento comida ducha baño Todo lo
necesario para vivir sobre el terreno de
4 a 6 semanas en las horas que siguieron
al terremoto Turquía pidió ayuda
internacional haciendo un llamado al
mecanismo europeo de Protección Civil
Turquía está sufriendo una crisis con
una catástrofe real y la comisión
europea respondió de manera masiva más
de 80 países están presentes en Turquía
con cerca de 10.000 efectivos sobre el
terreno
apreciamos mucho que todos los amigos
los aliados estén con nosotros en estos
momentos exigentes
después de la carga son los hombres y
mujeres que servirán en el hospital los
que aterrizan impacientes por comenzar
el trabajo
podemos tratar acerca de 100 personas al
día pero eso depende de la seriedad de
las heridas en total tenemos capacidad
de 75 camas además de los pacientes
diarios además de 100.000 heridos
problemas sanitarios infecciones y
enfermedades entre tanto la vida diaria
continúa con rasguños y golpes
nacimientos y enfermedades crónicas
incluso después de un terremoto